This is Every Country in the World Part 2
By Wendover Productions.
If you haven’t seen part 1, click here to
watch that first.
We left off last time in Suriname, our 98th
country.
Suriname is the only county other than the
Netherlands whose sole primary language is
Dutch, although there are other countries
that speak a creole version of Dutch like
Namibia which speaks Afrikaans which is just
close enough to Dutch that a Dutch and Namibian
could hold a conversation.
Namibia has this long protrusion which gives
them access to the Zambezi river although
they miss out by about 300 feet on bordering
Zimbabwe which is the country ferries have
the pass through when making the 600 foot
trip from Botswana to Zambia.
This is likely the shortest ferry in the world
to cross through three countries.
To the northeast of Zambia is one of the world’s
176 tripoints—triple border crossings.
This one links Zambia to Malawi and Tanzania
whose northern border is a very straight line
across Lake Victoria which creates these two
tiny
cut off peninsulas.
Uganda is a surprisingly progressive nation
with the highest representation of
women in parliament in the world at 63%.
They also became the first country in the
world to
outright ban plastic bags in 2007.
The Solomon islands, on the other hand, only
has one woman
in their parliament or 2% representation.
The Solomon Islands is home to the West Georgia
islands which share a name with Georgia which
kinda shares a name with Georges Plain in
Jamaica which is one of two countries in the
world whose flag doesn't share colors with
the
American flag—as in, no red, white, or blue.
The other one is Mauritania, but Libya used
to be on that list until they changed their
flag from this to this in 2011.
Libya is so
large that its northwest point is closer to
to Luxembourg than to its southeast point.
Luxembourg
has the second highest per capita income in
the world behind Qatar—a small but mighty
country
thats just a bit larger than Lebanon who shares
a southern border with the United Nations
Disengagement Observer Force Zone which is
an area essentially without sovereignty meant
to
serve as a buffer between Israeli controlled
Syria and Syria.
One could call it… a de-militarized
zone, although the most famous DMZ is north
of South Korea where, if you dig a hole straight
down and through the earth, you’d pop up
just off the coast of Uruguay.
Uruguay was a military
dictatorship up until 1985 but Thailand still
is—the only current one.
Bangkok, Thailand is the
most visited city in the world at 16 million
yearly visitors which is a ton, especially
compared to
Vilnius, Lithuania which only sees 180,000
visitors per year.
Lithuania has a rather straight
border though this lake which leads to two
peninsulas with their tops chopped off and
an
internationally divided island with Belarus
which has a rather straight border in this
lake which
leads to another peninsula with its top chopped
off and an internationally divided island
with
Latvia.
Latvia’s independence day is May the 4th
aka Star Wars day whose scenes on Tatooine
were filmed in Tunisia.
Tunisia’s currency is the Dinar, which is
also the name for the currency
in Macedonia.
If you look at Macedonia on a map, it will
almost always have FYROM under its
name which stands for Former Yugoslav Republic
of Macedonia.
When Macedonia became an
independent country it picked this name but
Greece wasn’t all too happy about that since
their
northern region is also called Macedonia so
the solution was to call the country the Former
Yugoslav Republic of Macedonia in all official
capacities, while colloquially its still known
as
Macedonia.
Greece is known for having a huge expatriated
population around the world and the
39th largest greek population in the world
is in Oman in the middle east.
Inside Oman is an
exclave of the United Arab Emirates except
this part of Oman is actually an enclave inside
the
UAE which makes this the only double enclave
in the middle east.
The UAE is one of 18
countries worldwide to not have a river—one
of which is Tonga which actually has an olympic
medal from their super heavyweight boxer—Paea
Wolfgramm.
Another country that has one
total medal is Gabon whose southern border
is shared with Congo whose southern border
is
shared with this rather large exclave of Angola.
Only because of that exclave, Angola borders
both Congo and the Democratic Republic of
the Congo.
These are of course two different
countries although they’re both named for
the Congo River—the deepest river in the
world at
more than 750 feet deep.
Interestingly, despite being both enormous
countries, their current
capitals are just on opposite sides of the
Congo from each other.
The DRC has this great clean
border with Rwanda which causes no problems
at all unlike this one in Austria.
Jungholz is only
connected to the rest of Austria by about
15 feet of territory and no roads.
Vienna, Austria used to
be the capital of the Austria-Hungarian empire
whose territory included present-day Italy,
Poland, Germany, Croatia, Montenegro, Serbia,
(all of which we’ve already talked about)
and
Bosnia and Herzegovina, the Czech Republic,
Hungary, Romania, Slovakia, and Ukraine.
Ukraine has this southern section which isn’t
part of Russia yet, although its only connected
to
the rest of Ukraine by two roads, one of which
rather inconveniently passes through Moldova
for
only about 3 miles.
Moldova is rated the third least touristy
country in the world since only one
tourist visits each year for every 323 citizens
although Bangladesh is the number one least
touristy country since for each yearly tourist
visit there are 1273 Bangladeshi citizens.
Bahrain,
on the other hand, receives 7.7 tourist visits
per citizen per year and also has an internationally
divided island, but this one was actually
very purposefully created to serve as the
passport
control point between Bahrain and Saudi Arabia
on the King Fahd Causeway.
Saudi Arabia is
home to Mecca, the birthplace of the central
figure of Islam—the prophet Muhammad.
Mecca
has a population of about 1.5 million people
but during the Hajj—the yearly pilgrimage
to Mecca
—this triples to almost 5 million people.
Land in Mecca is some of the most expensive
in the
world at up to $13,000 per square foot.
Saudi Arabia really isn’t great friends
with their southern
neighbor—Yemem, who owns over 200 islands
including Socotra Island which is surprisingly
green compared to its mainland neighbors and
is the only place in the world where you can
find
the Dragons Blood Tree.
Yemen’s national soccer team has played
Bhutan three times in the past
few decades all of which Bhutan lost rather
horribly.
Bhutan is home to the Gangkhar Puensum
mountain which is believed to be the tallest
un-summited mountain in the world since local
spiritual beliefs prohibit anyone from climbing
a mountain over 6000 m (19500 feet).
This
mountain is in the himalayas range which if
you follow to the west brings you to Nepal
which if
of course home to Mount Everest—the tallest
mountain in the world.
Everest is 29,029 feet tall
—880 times higher than the Marshall Islands’
tallest peak at 33 feet.
If you dig a hole straight
down through the earth from the Marshall Islands
you arrive just off the coast of Liberia which
is
the country of registration of 11% of the
world’s ships.
Of the 2,771 registered ships, though,
only 190 are actually owned by Liberians.
Foreigners register their ships there since
there are
few regulations and low costs.
Malta also registers many ships for the same
reasons with 1,437
foreign owned ships.
Malta is a European Union member which means
that we've almost talked
about every EU member.
Our last two are Estonia and Ireland whose
northernmost point is
actually farther north than Northern Ireland’s.
Ireland has played Samoa six times in Rugby,
and
Samoa actually won once which is quite impressive
for a country of less than 200,000.
Samoa’s
rugby team did once lose to New Zealand 101-14
though—they’re not that good.
New Zealand
has a kinda territory of Niue.
It's recognized as a freely associated state--meaning
by choice—but
Niue isn't recognized by the UN as a independent
country.
However, Niue is exactly on the
opposite side of the world from Niger which
is named for the Niger River.
The Niger River has
probably the most bizarre river course in
the world—it starts only 150 miles from
the Atlantic
ocean but then takes a 2,600 mile path to
reach the ocean.
It starts in Sierra Leone, flows through
Guinea, Mali, Niger itself, then Benin before
reaching the ocean in Nigeria.
Nigeria is also
named after the Niger river and is by far
the most populous country in Africa at 125
million
people.
The least populous country in Africa is the
Seychelles which isn’t on the mainland but
still considered an African country.
They also have what might be the coolest flag
in the world
except for maybe Saint Lucia's, but I have
to give a solid runners up position to Saint
Vincent
and the Grenadines.
Saint Vincent and the Grenadines name is rather
purposefully similar to that
of its neighboring island—Grenada.
Grenada’s airport wasn't built until 1985
but nowadays you
can fly to places like Port of Spain in Trinidad
and Tobago.
Trinidad is also the name of
municipality of 20,000 people in Honduras
which has two capitals—Tegucigalpa and
Comayagüela—much like the Cote d’Ivoire
whose capitals are are Yamoussoukro and Abidjan.
Despite having a very easy English translation—the
Ivory coast—the Cote d’Ivoire is almost
always referred to by this name since its
government refuses to accept any translated
name.
If
you draw a straight line south from Cote d’Ivoire
until it crosses Antartica and goes North
you’ll
end up intersecting Vanuatu which is one of
seven countries worldwide to not be part of
the
International Criminal Police Organization
also known as INTERPOL.
Another non-
INTERPOL-member country is Tuvalu which is
the second smallest country in the world to
have
a commercial international airport.
This is also the second video in a row that
I’ve used this
image—watch my last video to find out why.
Nauru is the smallest country outright to
have an
airport and it rather controversially has
camps for those who attempt to seek asylum
in Australia,
many of whom are from Iraq.
Iraq borders Iran, which has 22 ski resorts.
That’s more then the
entire South American continent.
Speaking of South America, we haven’t covered
Paraguay
which is another one of these landlocked countries
with a navy and with that, we’ve touched
on
every South American country!
If you dig a hole through the earth from Paraguay
and you end
up just north of Philippines which is our
seventh to last Asian country.
The other ones are
Myanmar which is one of the worlds three countries
not using the metric system; Timor-Leste
whose currency is the US dollar despite having
no real connection to the US; Pakistan which
is
home to the third-largest non-polar glacier
in the world despite being at the same latitude
of
South Texas; Jordan which you might think
is landlocked from looking at a map but actually
has
a 16 mile coast on the red sea; Syria which
is home to Damascus—the oldest continuously
inhabited city on the planet; and Kuwait which
has the highest value currency in the world
at 3.3
US dollars to each Kuwaiti Dinar.
With that, we've covered every Asian country.
One of the
lowest value currencies in the world is the
Sao Tomé and Principe dobra at 23,000 dobra
to the
dollar.
Sao Tomé and Principe speaks Portuguese which
means we've covered every Portuguese
speaking country.
The country is also off the coast of Cameroon
which became the first African
country to reach the FIFA world cup semi-finals
in 1990, although that's since been
accomplished by Ghana where the official and
primary language is English and there are
only
three more countries like this—Belize, the
only English speaking country in central america;
Barbados, who has the third highest human
development index score in the western hemisphere;
and Antigua and Barbuda whose native language—Taino—is
the origin of english words like
Canoe, Barbecue, Hammock, and Hurricane.
So we’ve covered every English speaking
country
but there are two remaining countries that
were part of the British empire—Dominica,
where
Antillean Creole is the primary language;
and Mauritius which has the highest population
density
in Africa at over 1500 per sq/mi.
One of the lowest population densities in
Africa is in Central
African Republic at 18 people per sq/mi.
The Central African Republic’s northern
neighbor is
Chad whose embassy in Washington DC is only
about 200 feet away from that of Burkina Faso
whose capital has perhaps the best name in
the world—Ougadougou.
In the southeast of Burkina
Faso is this piece of Togo that is only connected
to the main part by a 300 foot wide strip
of land.
This area’s roads, however, all come from
Burkina Faso which means that, much like Point
Roberts, residents need to cross two international
borders to get to their own country.
There are
only three African countries left—Comoros,
the second largest vanilla producer in the
world;
Burundi, the poorest country in the world
to have an olympic medal; and Eritrea, which
has
neither an official or majority spoken language.
Drawing a latitude line west from Eritrea
brings
you to Nicaragua—home to a lake on an island
in a lake.
More than 100,000 nicaraguans live in
nearby El Salvador which is the smallest central
American country and only one to not have
a
Caribbean coastline.
El Salvador’s northern neighbor is Guatemala
whose border with Mexico
was originally defined by the course of the
Chixoy river but erosion has changed the course
which created a bunch of enclaves and exclaves
like this, this, and this.
And that’s our last
country in the western hemisphere!
We're getting close!
Guatemala's embassy in Ottawa is about
900 feet away from Slovenia's which has this
really messed up border with Croatia including
this
tiny section that isn't actually claimed by
either country making it terra nullis.
The 10th and final
country to end in -nia and our final country
is Albania whose capital is one of the only
in Europe
to not have a McDonalds.
But wait, if you draw a latitude line from
the south of Albania that
brings you to the north of Afghanistan where
Albania sent 44 troops to fight in 2005 and
where
we started this video so if you’re feeling
like a second round, click here to go to the
start again.
I hope you enjoyed this Wendover Productions
video.
I’m very happy to announce that I’ve partnered
with DFTBA to bring you Wendover Productions
t-shirts which look like this.
There are two ways to get one of these.
You can become a Patron on Patreon at the
$20 level and receive a bunch of great other
perks like stickers, handwritten letters,
early access to videos, behind the scenes
updates, and more, or you can just purchase
the shirt by itself for the very reasonable
cost of $20 and have it shipped to anywhere
in the world.
This is the link to order that shirt or its
also in the description.
Other than that, please be sure to subscribe
to catch every one of my videos right when
it comes out, follow me on twitter @WendoverPro,
check out part 1 of Every Country in the World,
take a look at my fan moderated subreddit
at reddit.com/r/WendoverProductions, and contribute
to my Patreon at patreon.com/WendoverProductions.
Thanks again for watching, and I’ll see
you next tuesday for another Wendover Productions
Video.